so I want to give a shout out to Mary
Ellen to Troy to Sharon to heg to Andy
to uh is that Daisy
Joseph wait DST DST Joseph Tara or Tara
Daryl Cassidy David Jonathan
Jamie uh
Jared I can't even read my own writing I
have a marker board here and it's kind
of smeared but Edgar Edgar God bless you
brother thank you so much Peter and
Daryl we love you guys and we thank you
so much we can't do this without you
guys so thank you for your love and
support if you want to support this
ministry you can do so through cash app
vinmo zel and if you go to our website
you'll see a spot to click donate and
that's and there you can donate through
PayPal you can do it monthly or whatever
we also have merch if you guys like cool
t-shirts where you can have a
conversation starter sometimes it's hard
to talk about the gospel with people and
this gives you you know just something
to wear that people say whoa what what's
that mean or that's a really cool shirt
and you can say yeah it's actually based
on a Bible verse welcome to candid truth
we're going to talk about the truth and
we're going to get candid with it
tonight we're going to talk about
alcohol wine beer strong drink liquor
all the things that so many people love
and what does the Bible have to say
about it I hear different answers
depending on which Christian you ask but
we want to get the truth I don't care if
it's if the Bible says it's okay to
drink or if it says it's not okay to
drink at all I want to live by the truth
I've you know my life has been totally
changed by Christ and by his word I used
to uh even as a self-professed Christian
for eight years I wasn't in God's word
and I wasn't seeing the scriptures for
myself and I was living by well what
does my cousin say or what does this
certain Pastor say and you know that's
how Satan speaks he speaks in truth
mixed with error so when he was in the
Garden of Eden with Eve he said did not
God say you could eat of every tree of
the garden that was a true statement God
really did say that but he left off the
ending that said all but this one and so
99 % truth is not truth it's deception
and it's easy to cherry-pick scriptures
here and there and say you know what
this is truth because this one Bible
verse says it what about these 50 no I
don't want to see this 50 this one and
that's what I see happen with all kinds
of beliefs and fundamental doctrines and
things like that you know there's
there's uh debates about what happens
when you die do you go straight to
heaven do you sleep until Jesus comes
back and and you can see the argument
for both sides if you look at one
scripture but when you look at the whole
of scripture what is it teaching and so
we want to look at all the scriptures we
want to study them line upon line
precept upon precept here a little there
little little by the mouth of two or
three Witnesses and go by the uh you
know the standard of what the Bible says
not just one verse that might be taken
out of context so the argument that I
actually saw in our
like our our posts and stuff is people
are saying wine means wine because I was
I was showing how sometimes the word
wine actually means grape juice in the
Bible and I actually heard people more
than one person say wine means one what
do you think
about um I think that that's the crooks
of the matter which we have to look
further the Bible to actually understand
yeah
so you know it's interesting wine means
wine because that's like saying gay
means
gay does gay mean gay I mean today if
you say I'm gay that means you're
homosexual Case Closed there's no other
like you just said you're gay but has
that always been the case no yeah what's
an example here the Flint Stones
apparently in their song is that the
song yeah so on the Flint Stones they
said uh you know Flint Stones Meet The
Flintstones and it said says have a y
daa do time a daao time we'll have a gay
old time now the word gay back when this
cartoon first came out did not mean
we're going to have a homosexual time no
so therefore the words have different
meanings depending on the time that
you're living in it also they have
different meanings depending on what
nation you're in what language you're
speaking
because sometimes in Hebrew they might
have a a word like we have the word love
I love burritos I love my wife and I
love my dad right but I love them all
differently but we still use the word
love whereas in the Hebrew they have
like agape love what's the other one
like Phil Philadelphia or something um
yeah Philadelphia means Brotherly Love
or something so
sometimes uh these other nations have m
multiple words for for love whereas we
have one word for love and sometimes
there's fewer words so in the Bible they
use the word wine well they use the a
word that got translated to the English
word wine but there was only one word to
mean juice and alcoholic fermented wine
it was just one word in the Hebrew the
word yen is that how you say it I I
heard it yayin yayin this is the word
that we see when it talks about wine in
the Bible the the word that we see in
the English translation for wine is
actually sometimes it's this Hebrew word
Yan and and see where it says fermented
and unfermented grape juice that term
can mean both so already we see that
wine doesn't just mean wine and then
below it says it can mean both alcoholic
wine and non-alcoholic
grape
juice uh there's another word in the
Aramaic that looks like it says
hamara and that word means fermented and
unfermented grape juice so just because
you see a scripture that says and he was
drinking hamara and was happy does not
necessarily mean he was drinking alcohol
and was happy or drunk or something it
could mean he was drinking grape juice
in the Greek there's the word oos and it
means the same thing it
means both fermented and unfermented
wine notice the notice what it says
there
unfermented what wine wine it doesn't
say unfermented grape juice some of
these other ones say grape juice but
this actually uses the word unfermented
wine meaning it's not alcoholic and it's
juice it's not it is wine it's wine it's
just not wine that we think of today so
here here's an example of wine meaning
juice you want to read that Aubrey it
says and gladness is taken away and joy
out of the plentiful field and in The
Vineyards there shall be no singing
neither shall there be shouting the
treaders shall tread out no wine in
their presses I have made their vintage
shouting to cease so what do you when
you read that what do you think about
that word wine what does it
mean well if it's actually treading out
in their presses what is the first stage
of of doing presses of grape juice
it's it's grape juice yeah it's not
fermented right if you put grapes in the
Press you're not going to push out
alcohol right it doesn't happen alcohol
is a whole fermented process of allowing
The Grapes to rot and ferment and
explain the fermentation process a
little bit you understood something
about on the skin of it and
everything so when you want something to
ferment usually there's a bacteria or
Yeast I'm not sure which one that
actually gathers on the skin of fruits
specifically grapes are perfect because
they have a high level of sugar and then
they usually have a higher amount of
yeast on the outside as well that
contributes to the fermentation process
um without it it wouldn't happen but you
have to
actually allow that to happen um I've
made my my own yeast for baking bread
and I've had to make that before how'
you make it I actually because I when I
see yeast it's like a bag of powder or
something yeah so I looked up how they
did it biblically and I I followed that
method um you fill a a jar basically
with a bunch of cut up pieces of apple
and you do not wash the Apple before you
actually put it in there you have to
leave all that bacteria and whatever on
it um and then you put a few grapes
inside and you also put some honey you
want to feed it extra sugar but if you
do the grapes usually you can forgo the
extra honey you mix it up you let all
that bacteria get really well mixed and
then you let it sit once you filled it
with water on the counter or something
yep and open usually with a cheesecloth
or something to let it breathe if you
don't there'll be worms will get in
there and stuff yes or it just won't
ferment properly truly if it's not if
it's closed and shut airtight nothing
will happen so that in its thoroughness
is how you do that and how you create
like apple cider vinegar for one if you
were let it to go longer than that it
would turn into not just the yeast but
it would turn into
ACV and so there you go okay yeah I'm
not not ignorant on this I've made wine
in the past and you yeah you're putting
the grape juice in there and the yeast
and sugar lots of sugar actually helps
it fir it because these yeast actually
feed on sugar and then what they do is
they actually oh which I hate to bring
this into everything but maybe it's the
wrong time but usually that's the very
combination in your body that causes
the c word in health oh yeah we've heard
that you can't say the c word on uh yeah
YouTube what causes tumors in the body
and obviously usually going into an
oncology um W yeah so let's look at some
more then because this is an example
where wine does not mean alcohol this is
grapes being pressed out of the press
and it uses the word wine which today we
think means only alcoholic wine and so
people say wine means wine but it
doesn't mean wine coming out of the
presses right U here's another example
where it says in judges 9:13 you want to
read that and the vine said unto them
should I leave my wine which cheth God
and man and go to be promoted over the
trees okay so this is very interesting
because it says the vine said now
alcohol doesn't grow on a vine no and it
says should I leave my wine that does
what cheers up
who God and man and man I don't believe
that God is drinking alcohol I just
don't alcohol is ethanol it's a toxic
chemical that harms the body right and I
don't want people to think uh this is
like a bias of mine personally I'm just
telling you the truth there's so many
people right now you know the news used
to say a lot of times like these
articles and stuff would say oh a little
bit of wine is actually good for your
heart you drink a glass of wine every
day and all that now I mean I'm seeing
so many videos by doctors and health
experts that are
saying it even one glass is harming you
and we're going to show some of that but
this this is what happens in the
scientific world the Science World is
all about okay we think we see studies
saying this so let's tell everybody and
then we're going to keep looking at it
but wait a minute now that everybody has
been taking our advice we're actually
seeing something different but speaking
of biases they are paid by certain
companies we all should know this true
yeah to say a certain something usually
about drinks wine and alcohol and dairy
and all the things in the meat industry
and everything that truly does seem to
hinder our body and burden it right so
who is funding the studies if you really
look into it I mean this is like
conspiracy theory world but it's not
Theory this is fact um even in like the
meat industry and all this kind of stuff
that pyramid that table of you know what
do they call it the food pyramid when I
was growing up it was like in the
textbooks they're saying how corrupt
that thing is and it's not even true or
accurate and it's actually terrible for
your health but we were told you know
you got to have meat you got to have
dairy for strong bones and all this
stuff and now they're finding out none
of that's true and is actually funded
those studies were paid for by the meat
industry by the dairy industry and they
were getting Kickbacks and so it's all
this corrupt system and we know that
this is Satan's World he's a God of this
world that the love of money is the root
of all evil and if you
can make money by skewing the
information or by putting a chemical in
a product that makes it last longer on
the Shelf even if it is a little toxic
uh it's okay because you can make more
money on it
right so let's look at another verse
here um so we want to look at water into
wine because often times in this
discussion when you talk about is it
okay to drink alcohol people say well
Jesus turn water into wine this was what
I used I used to as a Christian I would
drink and I'd say Jesus turned water
into wine I also you know would
fornicate and say that Solomon had a
thousand wives and concubines and I
would smoke marijuana and say that
Genesis says every green herb is for man
but this is how Satan speaks Satan loves
to twist the truth and so I'm not saying
Jesus didn't turn water into wine he
most certainly did it's in the Bible but
we got to look at again what does this
word mean we're looking at it through a
you know 20th
century understanding of this term but
we just saw that for a fact the word
wine does not always mean alcohol in the
Bible mhm so you going to read that when
the ruler of the feast had tasted the
water that was made wine and knew not
whence it was but the servants which
drew the water knew drew the water knew
the governor of the feast called the
bridegroom okay so we see that clearly
Jesus turned water into wine says he
made the water into wine so here's some
points to consider
though in John 2:6 it says and there
were set or and there were set there six
water pots of stone after the manner of
the purifying of the Jews containing two
or three fing fens a piece so these
water pots held two or three furens what
is that know I don't know well when you
look it up because actually in the
alcoholic world it is still uh a
measurement I think found that out but I
guess it's like barrels or something but
here underneath the picture you see it
says unit firin and it's 10.8 gallons
okay so if one water pot has two or
three of these that means more than 20
or 30 gallons each so that's what the
the it says right here underneath it
says six Stone jars with 20 to 30
gallons of wine in them totaling
120 to 180 gallons of
wine so what kind of wine that's what I
want to know the question is were these
people at this wedding getting drunk
because in John 2:10 it says and saith
unto him so the the the master of the
feast he has tasted the wine and he's
saying whoa this is like the best wine
I've ever tasted and this is what he
says he says and he says unto him every
man at the beginning does set forth good
wine and when men have well drunk then
that which is worse but thou has kept
the good wine until now so look
everybody was drunk at this party so
clearly it was alcoholic wine right
that's what it says once they're all
drunk then you bring out the good wine
people use this text for one he's
actually he's not saying that's what's
happening at this party he's just saying
that's what usually happens but I'm not
going to like try and stretch I think
that is what's happening here um people
use this and say
well why it was clearly alcoholic wine
because he said people bring out the the
worst wine last that doesn't really mean
that if I'm if I'm serving grape juice
if I if I had a whole bunch of grape
juice and I knew that the last of the
batch was kind of like watered down and
stuff and I had a bunch of guests over I
would be serving them the best first
because I was like hopefully they don't
taste that other stuff it doesn't mean
it's
alcoholic one thing um I don't think I
even put it in here is if this guy was
drunk how is he even tasting how good
the wine is I've been drunk many times
in my life daily for years and the more
you drink the less you taste that's why
people are sit around they're like oh it
just tastes like water but I want to
look at something about this verse
because this is in the King James and
I'm that's the version I prefer but it's
still an English translated version so I
want to look at the
original so here in the Greek in the
concordance you see where it
says in multiple different variations it
says drunk
freely well drunk in the King James and
again it right here says drunk freely so
this word I don't even know how to say
that word in the Greek it's Greek to me
uh meth
methin methos
methin this word means to be filled when
you really study it out you'll see a lot
of scripture that tells you it just
means to be filled now if you're filled
on alcohol yeah you're G to be drunk but
if you're filled on grape juice you're
not going to be drunk if you're filled
on water you're not going to be drunk so
you can drink freely or be well drunk on
many different substances and in the
Greek it's break down each word and it
says and when they have drunk freely
this is what this word means this meth
how do you say that methin methin means
to drink freely or to be filled
with meth meth thos now a lot of this
text will be really small if you're
looking on a phone or something but
these are all examples of where this
word these are old test
okay so the Old Testament was written in
Hebrew and Aramaic but the Old Testament
has also been translated into Greek now
these languages were comparable because
of when they were written the time they
written and you have verses that say
things like you prepared a table before
me in the presence of my enemies and you
have anointed my head with oil my cup
overflows now this word over overflows
is the same word it doesn't say it's
alcohol it doesn't say he's being drunk
so there's a lot of these verses that
mean to be
soaked um with water it said right but
with water you filled so watering the
Earth all these are terms that mean to
be filled abundance overflowing okay so
same word yeah okay if you translate the
Old Testament into Greek okay um there
are there are
other uh uh scriptures in the New
Testament such
as John
2:10 and it says this is what we just
read this word well drunk but compare
that to 1 Corinthians 11:12 that says
for eating each one takes his own supper
ahead of the other and one is hungry and
the other is drunk that's what it says
when you read the Bible but it doesn't
really make sense in the context the
context here is saying some people are
getting to eat and others aren't so if
I'm understanding this correctly that's
also the same word yeah it means to be
filled okay so in this scripture when it
says for an eating each one takes his
own supper we're looking at food here
right ahead of another and one is hungry
and the other is filled yeah one is
hungry and the other is filled on food
the context is what matters it's like
this word means to be filled are you
fill filled with food are you filled
with water are you filled with grape
juice all these things you can be filled
with and and you it's a bad translation
to say drunk to say drunk every time it
says filled like if I was like oh man I
ate so much I'm so full so I wouldn't
say I'm drunk I'll just emphasize that's
why you need to look at different
translations in the Greek and Aramaic
and Hebrew because there's a lot of
things in the Bible that are
actually poorly translated into English
from their original
translation yeah and there's some people
that get real excited when you say that
or real uh offended because they're like
God said he'll preserve his word and the
King James version is perfect and all
that I believe that God's word is
preserved enough to teach us the truth
salvation and all that but when it comes
to some of these nuances and some of
these deeper topics like does wine mean
wine we clearly saw it didn't that's not
that's not any error on the writers it's
an error in the translation and so if we
really want to study the Bible out
diligently and search it out like we're
searching for gold anytime I see
something in Scripture that looks like a
contradiction I know the Bible doesn't
contradict itself right I know this and
so therefore I have to dig deep if that
means going to the Greek and the Hebrew
I'm going to do it I'm not I'm not to
the level where I'm like the King James
English translation is Flawless to the
to my 20th century American mind that's
not true now when when they translated
it I bet King James knew that wine also
me I mean in that time even in English
wine meant both I even found an article
maybe we can attach it but I found that
many of the people in the medieval times
Middle Ages times all this stuff they
understood a lot of the the terms of
wine making a lot better yeah and they
had other terms for it like must and
must
meant in their words from even
understanding the
Bible um you could see that it meant
unfermented wine right and so we'll look
at some of that too so that was an
example so now ask yourself what would
Jesus
do so it said six stones with 20 to 30
gallons of wine each that's 120 or 100
anywhere from 120 to 180 gallons of wine
ask yourself what would Jesus do would
Jesus make 120 gallons of
alcohol for a party of people who are
already well drunk no we have to be
honest with
ourselves God said drunkers will not
inherit the kingdom of God will God ever
tempt you with evil no way so if people
are already drunk at this party you
think he's gonna say hey I know you're
all drunk but look at all this 120
gallons of it drink up boys he's not
going to say you know what I made all
this wine but you guys are already drunk
so I trust that you will practice
moderation no so already there that to
me is Case Closed either these people
aren't drunk and this is alcoholic this
is non-alcoholic wine or maybe they were
drunk but Jesus didn't add more alcohol
to the party he gave fresh juice right I
think in keeping with his character and
the fact that he wants you to flee from
evil in any right any semblance of evil
that he wouldn't dangle a carrot like
that that's right that's bad no
never and so now ask yourself another
question does Jesus create life or death
because you cannot have fermented
alcoholic ethanol without death yeah
alcoholic wine is rotting grapes that
are being consumed by bugs causing
fermentation I don't think Jesus said
watch this boom miracle I just made
rotten grapes he wouldn't do that he
creates life everything in him I am the
way the truth and the life he cannot
produce death because he is life
and so therefore he would not produce
fermented alcoholic
wine so let's check this out um this is
just some of the effects of alcohol
would Jesus produce a chemical like this
for maybe hundreds of people at this
party to consume when the effects of
this substance is
terrible it doesn't look like much but
the liver is Central to our dig gestion
for breaking down food and other
substances in the body when the liver
has to repeatedly break down more than a
little alcohol it struggles to do its
job and can become at first fatty and
then scarred causing irreparable damage
to this vital organ and liver failure is
fatal regularly drinking more than 14
units a week can cause serious harm to
your liver the more you drink above that
limit the higher your risk of developing
alcohol rated liver disease it's
estimated that alcohol rated fatty liver
disease develops in 90% of people who
drink more than four units a day that's
roughly the equivalent of two medium
glasses of wine or less than two pints
of regular strength Beer a Day the
easiest way to protect your liver and
lower your health risks from alcohol is
to stay within the chief medical
officers low-risk drinking guidelines of
not more than 14 units a week including
several drink free days spread evenly
throughout the week and no binging when
you're ready to drink less drink aware
is here here to help to find out how
search drink aware change starts with
you now I think it's interesting that
this substance is so toxic and so
addictive that we have to have
commercials like this this this is a
commercial but that we have to have
warnings on this you know it's
like even if you don't don't even drink
every single day don't even drink one
drink this is a substance that has
caused
millions of deaths broken
families sickness addiction all these
things it's destroyed lives on so many
levels and yet we try to say we try to
justify and say well Jesus made it for
everybody no he made juice of the vine
somebody here said something about we
are condemning people I haven't
condemned anybody we are reading
scripture for what it says we're we're
studying it line upon line we're not the
judge we're not here to point fingers or
condemn anyone we're saying what does
the Bible say and I am at the place and
have been for years now where I say if
the Bible says it that's what I want to
do I don't care if it goes against
everything I've ever believed you know
I've heard people say why are you
wearing a wedding ring that that's Pagan
or whatever the Bible doesn't condemn a
wedding ring the Bible says that uh
there was a parable about uh the love of
the father and when his son left him
when the son returned the father ran to
him kissed him put a robe on him put a
ring on his finger why would there be a
parable about the love of God and how
much he loves his children and he puts a
ring on his finger and there's another
verse that says that you know we are the
bride of Christ and it says that we are
decked like a a bride is decked for her
groom and decked in in Jewels it says so
when you think about where his bride and
we're his children and he puts a ring on
the finger of the child and he puts
jewels on the wife it makes sense I mean
we wear this to show that we're taken so
that when we go out in public people
don't say you know try to hit on you or
whatever for us it's just a sign to to
show other people that we're married and
because if you do it Tastefully you are
not actually
being crazy in the way that you wear
tons of it it's also within bound
boundaries of being modest and of God
yeah and people want to say that with
alcohol like moderation and all that um
we're going to see if there's actually a
moderate amount of alcohol that the
Bible according to the Bible yeah
according to the Bible we can we can
stick with tradition if you want to we
can justify a lot of things with
tradition and culture I'm done with that
I don't want tradition and culture I
want God's word and what he
says so
here we see two other verses that people
like to use to justify drinking the wine
that maketh glad the heart of man and
oil to make his face to shine and bread
which strengtheneth man's
heart and then the second one drink no
longer water but use a little wine for
thy stomach's sake and thine often
infirmities yeah so a lot of times
people will take this verse and say
oh the Bible says a little wine for the
stomach it's like you must have some
serious stomach issues if you're
constantly drinking every day you drink
for your stomach's sake no um and it
says wine makes the makes glad the heart
and so people are like that's got to be
talking about alcohol because it makes
you glad you know so we're going to look
at that can these be referring to grape
juice we'll find out so here's an
article from medicine net this is one of
many but it
says why does grape juice make me feel
better
H wait a minute makes the heart glad for
your stomach for infirmities remember
these scriptures we just saw and it says
here it says grape juice is rich in
Sugar potassium iron and antioxidants
which all help provide the body with
extra energy and act as a mood booster
oh wait makes you glad right grape juice
gives us extra energy and acts as a mood
booster that will eventually make us
feel better so you know people read some
of this stuff they're like it makes you
marry it makes you glad all these things
that comes from grape juice that does
not come from fermented rotten alcohol
yeah it does affect your mood it totally
Alters your
mood and it goes on and continues it
lists a whole lot of great things that
it does for the body but one of them is
digestive health and the other one is
heart health doesn't that line up
exactly with what we just read drink a
little wine for thy stomach sake which
is digestive health and drink it for a
heart wouldn't that make your heart glad
I don't see this scripture as saying
wine makes a man glad it might but what
I see is it makes the heart glad I think
God is really specifically telling you
what it's doing it's making you have a
happy healthy body and either way it
works because we just read that it's a
mood
booster and here's another website
that's medical news today and it says
how grape compounds can help to treat
depression talk about happy this is is
they're using grapes now to cure
depression praise God that they're
finding something natural instead of
this pharmac phakia sorcery it says a
new study notice this is new the science
is finally catching up to the Bible a
new study unravels the me mechanisms by
which compounds found in grapes improve
resilience to stress in m and tenent the
Brain changes linked with depression so
here we see that grapes grape juice it
lifts your mood it can help depression
helps your stomach and helps your heart
everything that the says so we cannot
look at these verses and say oh yep
makes a heart glad I'm going to get
glad by the
way this is water but I thought it would
be kind of ironic to do a show where
we're drinking out of brown bottles
because doesn't it just look weird
doesn't it look awkward to see a
Ministry saying what's up everybody
we're gonna look at the
Bible who woo that's strong there's
nothing good
about alcohol that makes you cringe and
say you know that's good stuff right
there um so we're seeing that the Bible
so far is 100% accurate and science is
catching
up here the article continues and it
says he continues the discovery of these
new natural grape derived
polyphenols polyphenols compounds
targeted cellular and molecular Pathways
associated with inflammation May provide
an effective way to treat a subset of
people with depression and anxiety a
condition that affects so many people so
the Bible is 100% accurate when it says
that wine or grape juice makes the heart
glad right so I want to show you a
commercial just to let you see a visual
of how glad and how happy that this
juice can make a
person it's naturally sweet really
really that's why Welter 100% grape
juice doesn't just taste really good M
it's also really good for you too 40 Wes
is the best juice in the world it's
yummy can't you see the gladness on her
face and notice on the bottle it has a
heart and it says that it's good for
your heart this commercial was from the
90s so they were already knowing this
stuff you know people they want to say
oh you know wine is good for the heart
because it's made out of grapes but the
grapes are rotten and now the the
ingredients that are in that thing the
properties that in that that are good
for your heart are no longer good the
the bad outweigh the good uh you could
say bleach it's got some water in it
that's good for you drink up we can't
just
justify terrible things because it has a
good ingredient in
it um let's check out what alcohol
really does for your heart because now
this is this is science this isn't this
isn't a religious thing I'm not showing
you
religious uh studies or religious bias
things here we're just looking at
science at this point
[Music]
[Laughter]
so you can see alcohol is not good for
the heart at all it's actually terrible
for your heart and you know when when
you talk about a subject like this
that's a controversial touchy one that
might even step on some toes people want
to point the finger and try to find any
reason why they shouldn't have to listen
to you we could do this video Behind uh
we could not show our faces we could not
show our bodies or whatever and you
wouldn't be able to point the finger
somebody wants to do a study on dress
reform I invite you on let's do it that'
be amazing I'd love to hear about that
somebody said um they gave the the
scripture about that the son of man
comes eating and drinking drinking and
they called him a glutton and a drunk so
do you believe that Jesus was a glutton
because gluttony is
sin so yeah he was eating he wasn't
glutting he was drinking something in a
big uh wine skin and he never drank
fermented rotten alcohol that shrinks
your brain destroys your liver is bad
for your heart causes dryness of skin
all these things
he didn't do that Jesus never sinned he
never came close to sin just because he
was accused of being a
drunk now you're saying that Jesus is a
sinner he's a glutton and a drunk that's
crazy I could say I'm eating and you
don't know if I'm eating something clean
or unclean or whatever I could say I'm
drinking I could be drinking water this
is water but you for all you know it is
beer you know well that's the thing in a
that's a perfect example actually
somebody could say uh that guy is
drinking he look at him he's a glutton
and a drunk because I saw him drinking
out of a brown bottle on his show and
that's the thing they only had wine
skins for liquids back then especially
on the road and traveling so you you see
somebody drinking out of a big bag of
skin and they're like look there he is
and he's hanging out with Sinners of
course he hung out with people that were
drunks and Glutton isers because they
are the ones that need the gospel the
most he came for the Sinners not the the
well don't need a physician and that's
what he said so you know it's that
Guilty by association thing so I heard
somebody that I don't know why this came
up more than once but it they said Noah
had Noah had a
Vineyard
yeah and I think I would love to have a
Vineyard myself and I'm sober since 2013
I would love to have a Vineyard so so
here's an example of somebody that has a
Vineyard who does not produce alcohol
back in 1869 a New Jersey physician
named Thomas Bramwell Welch I want to
point out that this their Welch's bottle
actually says unfermented wine it
literally uses the word
wine awesome so they use the word wine
there so check it
out back in 1869 a new Jersey physician
named Thomas Bramwell Welch had this
crazy notion of creating unfermented
wine for communal services at his
church at the heart of the company's
success is the conquered and Niagara
grape we are unique in marketing Those
Grapes they have uh unique
characteristics not only the Bold Flavor
but also some very strong um health
benefits
so somebody said in the comments no I
got drunk he did and it was a
sin and any I could take any of these
grapes this Vineyard is for grape juice
by Welches but I could take these same
grapes and let them rot and drink it and
and get drunk on it this doesn't justify
drinking because Noah got drunk it was a
sin the Bible clearly says drunkards
will not inherit the kingdom of God
there's many scriptures that say that
drinking and being drunk is a sin why
are we saying Noah got drunk and acting
like that justifies drinking yeah it
doesn't this is
actually a recipe because some people
think and believe that there was no way
back then without refrigeration and
everything to preserve grape juice for
long periods of time it had to been
fermented that's the only way people say
that's the only way at the Last Supper
The Last Supper took place eight months
after the Harvest of grapes and so
people said there's no way that eight
months later they were drinking grape
juice it had to be fermented because it
was so because they didn't know they
didn't have the technology back then is
what they said these people are not dumb
I don't know why it's like we've been
brainwashed by Evolution and we think
that people in the past are like imals
no it says that we're going to be living
as in the days of Noah these people were
Geniuses and and um this was written in
a by who's that guy col colia or
something col we shall heat the furnace
at first with gentle fire and with only
very small pieces of wood which the
country people call cremia Brushwood so
that the must that's the word I
mentioned before made boil in a
leisurely manner the man in charge of
this boiling should have ready prepared
strainers made of rushes or broom but
the latter should be in a raw state that
is to say not beaten with a
hammer he should stir up any drgs which
have settled at the bottom and bring
them up to the top he should then clear
away with the strainer any scum which
remains on the surface and he should go
Sor go on doing this until the must
seems clear cleared of all Lea
if there is plenty of wood it is better
to boil the must and clear off all the
scum with the drgs if this is done a
tenth part will be lost but the rest
keeps good forever afterwards when it
has cooled you should pour it into
vessels cover it and seal it up in this
way it will keep longer and no harm will
befall it so I actually heard about this
recipe from a guy online who made a
video 11 years ago on YouTube and he
said you know there's a big debate about
whether they the Ancients could preserve
grape juice or not and he said um so i'
I got this recipe and I'm going to put
it to the test and he Juiced grapes and
he said you know what um when he Juiced
The Grapes his juicer his modern-day
juicer was juicing up the Skins as well
and he said what I'm doing is actually
more likely to ferment because the Skins
are in there he said when they would
Stomp The Grapes you're pushing juice
out you're not going to juice skins with
your feet and then they would sift the
skin off and you're getting just the
juice that's removing the yeast that's
removing the bug that produces the
fermentation so you're completely
removing it then you boil it which is
the same as what we call pasteurization
today that kills any bug in it and then
you bottle it and you put a lid on it
and you see it airtight with uh he he
said they used um olive oil to seal it
but they they could use wax I remember I
know that they sealed bottles with
wax and you could store it in a cave you
could store it underwater you could
store it in a hole in the ground there's
so many ways that they had Refrigeration
back then especially because you're
entering into the winter months or
whatever it was e and he so he he did a
couple different methods he did one
where you really boil it down cuz this
this recipe was you're going to lose
10% the other recipe was like you lose
50% or more and it becomes concentrated
and that's what it means when you have a
juice that's from concentrate they're
literally rehydrating that concentrated
I don't know was is that must maybe the
concentrated must and it turns back in
the juice they were doing all this stuff
back then they had this type of they
called it glucose glucose glucose in the
Greek when it's concentrate that can be
re substantiated with water right that's
where we get the word glucose so this is
proof historically that they did have
the technology if you will to store
grape juice for long periods of time
this guy said it'll stay good forever
and it'll never see uh no harm will ever
befallen you can buy grape juice today
that's aged grape juice 5 years old and
it's unfermented it's non-alcoholic and
it they say it has a better silkier
taste so there is something to aged wine
that makes it more flavorful but it
doesn't have to be alcoholic and so yeah
in the Bible I didn't even include this
in the in the presentation but in the
Bible you'll see stuff about aged wine
but if it's ever spoken of in a positive
sense it wasn't alcoholic just you have
you'll learn that by the end of this so
here's some scriptures that a lot of
people use um um that say you know the
Bible says that wine is a blessing and
it's healthy it brings joy and yeah the
Bible does say that but as we've proved
the word wine can mean fermented or
unfermented juice so you see in all
these verses it says wine is a gift of
the goodness of God wine produces Joy it
gladdens the heart wine is used in
rejoicing before God um abundance of
wine it is is a particular blessing
blessing from God having no wi is a
hardship or a judgment of
God and the absence of wine results in
the absence of joy and wine will be part
of the future feasting in Christ's
Kingdom so I want to look at
specifically some of these here um the
abundance of wine is a particular
blessing from God so I believe that but
what does the Bible say what kind of
wine we have to look you can't look at
one scripture line upon line precept
upon precept by the mouth of two or
three Witnesses all kinds of false
doctrines have been created because
somebody took one verse and made a whole
fundamental belief out of it which wine
is blessed thus said the Lord as the new
wine is found in the cluster and one
saith destroy it not for a blessing is
in it so Will will I do for my servants
sakes that I may not destroy them all so
what kind of one in this verse is a
blessing straight from the cluster from
the cluster you don't get fermented
alcohol from a cluster from the vine
Yeah Yeah from the vine it's new wine
which means it's new and yes I know that
that word new wine is also used in
alcoholic sense when they said these men
are drunk on new wine I'm not making a
point that that phrase always means um
non-alcoholic wine but in this scenario
it says as the new wine is found in the
cluster in the cluster you can't have
alcohol in a cluster I've never bought
grapes and popped them in my mouth and
got drunk never happens and so if we're
going to read the Bible honestly and if
we're going to look at it for what the
Bible Alone says and throw out tradition
throw out culture what does the Bible
say we just read that there's a blessing
in the wine but what kind of blessing
which wine found in the cluster of the
new wine and now this because I'm really
surprised that people think that we're
going to be drinking alcohol in
heaven um Matthew 26:29 and he says but
I say unto you this is Jesus talking I
say unto you I will not drink henceforth
of this fruit of the vine until that day
when I drink it new with you in my
father's Kingdom how is he drinking the
wine usually God is very smart and he's
giving Clues as to what particular kind
of thing specifically he means yeah on
any topic right it's really our own it's
right in there yeah it's our own
ignorance it's our own desires like no
yeah Rebellion even that we our
addictions perhaps that are yeah things
that we don't want to give up speak for
us and it was hard for me to give up a
lot of things I gave up my favorite
movie
uh alcohol was my favorite weed alcohol
and weed man that was my all day every
day I loved it until I started reading
God's word and studying it and I said
God I want what you want for my life
I've been I chose my way and I'm
destroying it like my way is not good I
want your way God and so is there going
to be alcohol in heaven is the question
because in Matthew in Matthew 620 it
says but lay up for yourselves Treasures
in Heaven which neither moth nor rust
doth corrupt and where thieves do not
break through nor steal there is no
corruption in heaven yeah so answer me
this how are you going to have fermented
rotten grapes in heaven you can't case
Clos you can't this Doctrine alone which
you really have to go deep into history
over the mixing of good and evil or life
and death death in a balance of some
sort usually it is just the word
moderation is key there yeah if you
start looking it up is more of a gnostic
Catholic teaching yeah a balance of Good
and Evil the yin-yang philosophy and so
it was not if you will even a Christian
idea that came on the scene it was just
spread far and wide as
a undertone of supposed Christianity
because of these errors and thought yeah
the gnostics were an offshoot of
Christianity but it was totally the
opposite of Christianity right and I
just had a thought about that the the
balance of Good and
Evil the Bible says the complete
opposite what Fellowship does light have
with Darkness exactly it's like light
cannot coexist with Darkness if I go
into a dark room and I turn on a light
there's no more Darkness it's the
opposite and so why are we thinking that
we can do what the world does and
justify it biblically so let's check out
this news clip because new studies are
coming
out there's a sobering new study about
the long-term effects of alcohol having
just one drink a day could impact your
brain that's according to a new large
scale study in CBS 2's Bradley Blackburn
takes us through the findings many
people enjoy the occasional glass of
wine with dinner or a drink to wind down
at the end of the day red wine and
chocolate is a good combination I
usually have probably one drink later on
in the evening research has long shown
that those who drink heavily have
changes in the structure and size of the
brain that are associated with cognitive
impairments but now a new study finds
even just a few beers or glasses of wine
a week may also be risky were you
surprised by what you found I was I was
surprised at just how little alcohol
seems to be necessary to reduce brain
volume Dr Henry Craner and researchers
from the University of Pennsylvania
looked at data on more than 36,000
adults and found light to moderate
drinking was associated with reductions
in overall brain volume what happens in
cases where people drink far more than
one drink a day the reductions are
proportional so the more you drink the
smaller the volume for example in 50y
olds increasing drinking from about half
a Beer a Day to a pint of beer led to
changes in the brain equivalent to aging
2 years Dr crayler says the study's
findings are in contrast to current
guidelines on Safe Drinking limits say
no more than one drink per day for women
no more than two drinks per day for men
it's reasonable to have a small amount
of alcohol but I would discourage people
from drinking more than one or two
drinks on any occasion and no more than
probably seven drinks on average in a
week Dr Craner says about a third of the
adult population drinks more than
recommended so cutting back could have
real benefits Bradley Blackburn CBS News
New York so these are new studies these
are not Christian people they're saying
even as little as one glass you know
they're saying a couple of glasses of
wine a week a couple of glasses of beer
a week are causing your brain to
shrink why are we trying to justify this
toxic
ethanol alcohol you know what alcohol is
is for cleaning windows it's for
cleaning your table it's for cleaning
disinfecting a wound it's not for
consuming in your body it's ethanol this
and it's much more distilled in a
laboratory not that that makes it good
at all because you can't just drink tons
of ethanol and be like Oh but it's clean
and pure and the process it was made was
wonderful but yeah it was used in that
way the ones that were distilled cleaner
was used for cleaning and disinfecting
so we're we're
literally justifying going under our
sink and drinking a cleaning product
that's what we're doing yeah no I mean
that that's and when we're saying oh
just a little bit won't hurt well yeah
you can drink a maybe a small lid of
bleach it's not going to kill you but
why would anybody do it and try to
justify it the Bible doesn't want us to
do anything that harms our body if it's
harming your liver if it's harming your
heart like we just saw if it's harming
your brain making your brain shrink with
a couple glasses a week
this is forbidden by God because he
doesn't want us to destroy ourselves and
we're going to see a very clear verse on
that so alcohol equals illness and death
we just saw that Revelation 21:4 says
and God shall wipe away all tears from
their eyes and there shall be no more
death neither sorrow nor crying nor
shall there be any pain for the former
things are passed away is there going to
be alcohol in heaven
a place where there's no corruption no
death no sickness no because we just saw
that this toxic chemical shrinks your
brain destroys your liver and hurts your
heart it's not going to be in the
Kingdom of Heaven so we can already
prove that when Jesus said I'm G to
drink wine from the vine new from the
vine
new he's not saying hey we're GNA we're
going to drink up guys he's not I'm here
to spread truth I'm I'm here because the
truth will set you free believe me if
the Bible said it's okay to drink
alcohol I would do it because I love
alcohol and maybe I would refrain from
it all together because I like it too
much
but I'm seeing that the Bible wants us
to stay far from it that it's a toxic
chemical that destroys your body and
what's ironic is that it's the secular
people that are admitting it it's the
Christians that are trying to hold on to
it and say no a little bit's okay and
more more when I looked up when I looked
up on YouTube uh dangers of alcohol I'm
talking about all within the last couple
years these videos have millions of
views because so many people are waking
up and saying I want to be free I want
to be sober and how many people are
saying I haven't had a drink in months
and years and my life is great my health
is great my mind is great I can't
believe that I was enslaved to that
thing so many people are wanting to get
free from it and as Christians we're
wanting to say no I want to hold on to
it I want it it's the complete Twisted
thing it's exactly what the Bible says
in the last days is going to happen the
Christians are going to be lukewarm and
and God says I wish you were hot or cold
I wish you weren't sitting on the fence
and lukewarm like this this scripture
does appear
tricky it says it it appears that it's
saying to spend tith on alcohol in
Deuteronomy
14:26 it says and thou shalt bestow that
money it's talking about tithe money for
whatever thy Soul lusteth after for oxen
for sheep or for
wine remember this word wine can be
juice or
wine or for strong drink now that's
that's trickier because strong drink
definitely means
alcohol I think I mean unless somebody
can prove wrong actually somebody told
me that this strong drink could actually
mean that that concentrate that I was
talking about that strong potent
concentrate that you add water to and it
makes it fresh juice so it could mean
that but I'm not going to take that
angle because I can't prove that or for
strong drink or for whatsoever thy soul
desireth and thou shalt eat there of or
there before the Lord thy God and thou
shalt Rejoice thou and thine
household so that's a question too your
household can your children drink
wine can your household drink if it says
you and your household it didn't say no
just you and your wife or just you and
legal adults in there it said you and
your household are going to enjoy this
uh
wine and it says or strong drink so
let's look at this because this sounds
tricky when we go back to the uh
original language the Hebrew here notice
it's written backwards because Hebrew
goes from uh right to left and it says
for oxen for sheep for wine or similar
drink now that's a huge difference than
what we just saw in the King James Bible
it said for strong drink and like I said
now that might mean concentrated it
could mean that but I I can't back that
up but I can back up with the original
Hebrew says and it says or similar drink
so if this wine that the whole
household's going to enjoy which I don't
believe is fermented
ethanol is going to be enjoyed by the
household then similar drink could mean
hey you want some grape juice maybe you
want some apple juice as well something
similar to that grape juice I have to
stick with the Bible I have to stick
with what the word of God says if the
Hebrew says it I'm going with it I'm not
going to go with some English
translation that literally contradicts
everything the Bible says the Bible says
stay away from it um Daniel he refused
wine why why did he refuse the wine you
want to read this yeah so it says but
Daniel purposed in his heart that he
would not defile himself with the
portion of the king's meat nor with the
wine which he drank therefore he
requested of the prince of the Unix that
he might not defile himself prove thy
servants I beseech thee 10 days and let
them give up give us pulse to eat and
water to drink okay so pulse is
vegetables and water is water notice
what he says here he doesn't want to
defile himself defile himself defile
himself with what with the king's meat
or the wine the wine is defiling his
body why why wouldn't he just say well I
can have a little wine at
dinner right as long as I don't have too
much yeah Daniel could have withstood he
could have said I'll drink half that cup
but I know that's too much and I I won't
finish it why did he say I will I refuse
the wine give us pulse and water because
for one the the meat was unclean and the
wine was something that would defile his
body mhm now again precept upon precept
line upon line we got to see it line
upon line do not defile your temple know
ye not that you are the temple of God
and that the spirit of God dwelleth in
you if any man defile the temple of God
him shall God destroy for the temple of
God is Holy which Temple ye
are which Temple who are you you are the
temple of God and he says don't defile
it or I'll destroy you now what did
Daniel say he said don't I will not
defile myself with the wine do you think
he's talking about grape juice no in
this context he's not talking about
grape juice he's talking about fermented
wine but he wouldn't even drink it he
said give me water I won't defile myself
and the word of God says if you defile
your temple he will destroy you so can't
we look at the Bible and say well what
defiles a person unclean meat and
according to Daniel wine and many other
people people too but this isn't about
moderation you know I I keep seeing in
the you know comments and stuff like
well food is good unless you eat too
much then it's a sin that's true but
food is something that we need and is
given to us grapes grape juice is good
um sex is a great gift given by God but
when it's done outside of his design
whether it's
homosexuality um premarital sex
fornication adultery Pagan rituals yeah
so God created sex to be done a certain
way and not this way God created juice
and that's to be enjoyed but not this
way not when it's fermented and rotten
and shrinking your brain and defiling
your body it's actually a perfect
example I hate to say that but like
you're saying sex is amazing and God
made it to be his way MH but the pagans
when I went when I meant Pagan rituals I
actually meant you can go look at this
in Hindu temples they have tons of
usually um illustrations that are like
Kamas Sutra right yeah of all different
positions all the different partners
multiples beastiality sodomy everything
on Earth but this is what God said not
to do it's right do not look at what the
pagans do and worship me in that way
we're trying to redefine even what what
he meant for a grape and grape juice
like yeah sex has to be done his way and
not mimicking any of these other
positions and
ways and same thing for a grape you have
to have wine done his way yeah
from way yeah exactly that's a great
point so he he said it's a blessing when
it's in the cluster remember we read
that verse it's a blessing when it's in
the cluster but when is it defiled when
it in the cup and it spites like an
adder and when it's given to you by a
pagan yeah I will not drink of the
king's wine or you prepare it like a
pagan which if it does all those things
it would be fermented that's right so
man this is like this is new revelation
the more we go the more I study this the
more clear it gets I I it can't go back
the other way it can't um so we we know
that the blessing is in the cluster and
that Daniel said that it defiles him if
he drinks the King's Wine and God said
don't defile your temple or I will
destroy you that's strong language so
let's check out this commercial because
I love satire I love when you can use
comedy to tell the truth because that's
what makes something funny right a joke
isn't funny if there's no truth in it
like it just be like an elephant is a
pig haha there's nothing funny about it
but when you when you use things that's
what makes like stereotypes funny and
stuff like that even though they could
be hurtful there's a little truth to
that stuff and that's what makes them
funny and so this is not a Christian
site at all cracked is not a Christian
website at all it's actually pretty
crass and uh I know there was a magazine
that used to be like Mad Magazine this
is similar to that but this is honest
beer ad now like I said secular people
are being more honest than we are when
it comes to this topic Christians are
like nope it's good for your heart it
makes a person glad and secular World
saying no one glass can shrink your
brain and so I want you to hear these
are people who do drink I'm sure but
they just think it's funny to be honest
about a beer advertisement so check this
out carp signature summer Ales when
friends gather tradition craftsmanship
and quality blend together into an
affordable brain and liver poison we're
sure you'll love because it's chemically
dependence forming in a portion of the
population every bottle of carps is
guaranteed to kill enough of your brain
to impair your fine motor control
inhibitions and judgment but not enough
to kill you unless you drink enough of
it and actually it's not even that much
you have to drink it tastes okay how do
we do it we combine quality ingredients
with small animals called yeast and a
slurry of grain and water they eat it
and poop out the poison smooth authentic
poison then we seal them in a dark
airless container so they drown in their
own poop which we drink their rotting
corpses form the
bubbles that's addictive liver brain
poison the way your grandfather used to
order it my family's proud of our long
tradition of making fine gut
poison carps all natural it'll make you
feel different than you usually do in a
good way but then the next day it'll
feel like you were poisoned which you
were so don't be surprised or complain
to us about
it I'm Roger by the
way H I love it I mean it was so perfect
perfectly well said he's like it tastes
okay look we can't even justify this as
like well you know I just like the taste
of it you might if you were once an
alcoholic but nobody takes a sip of
tequila and is like wow I love that
flavor tastes good beer is like give a
beer to any child and you'll find out
the truth of the matter it doesn't taste
good it doesn't make a heart glad
they're spitting it out it's the
complete opposite of what grape juice
does for that happy girl when she was
like it's yummy right so we can't say
that we just like the taste of it and if
I drink a little bit then it's like and
I know people are going to be arguing I
do like the taste of it yeah because you
probably were an't alcoholic one time
that's all there's to I if I took a
drink of beer right now I would say um
that takes me back to some old
days but I'm not going to lie to myself
and say that is the tastiest beverage
I've ever had it's not true I'm not
gonna lie to myself um alcohol was
unclean in the temple you want to read
this verse M do not drink wine nor
strong
drink thou nor thy Sons with thee when
you go into the Tabernacle of the
congregation lest you die whoa that's
what what happens you die oh my goodness
okay it shall be a statute forever
throughout your
generations and that ye may put
difference between holy and Unholy and
between unclean and clean very
interesting what is the what is the
context of what the verse is saying what
what was the topic being talked about
right here drinking drinking wine and
strong drink and then what's it say at
the bottom put the difference
between unclean and clean
so is there an unclean so it's basically
saying look don't drink wine it doesn't
say don't get drunk it says don't drink
wine or period strong drink or strong
drink and then it says put un put a
difference between clean and unclean
don't do that in here only do clean
stuff in here that doesn't defile the
body that there's a blessing in the
cluster right someone just mentioned is
isn't that just for the priest well
we're GNA see yeah that was for the
priest
but I got a question for you is God a
respector of persons no it doesn't
matter if you have an opinion on it or a
preference or you're from one culture
background it the Bible stands true for
everybody the Bible says God is not a
respector of persons there's neither Jew
nor Greek We Are All One in Christ Jesus
we're we're uh Seed of Abraham HS
according to the promise yeah that's
what the Bible says now if we want to
take the whole Bible because that's what
we like to do we like to say nope that
was just for the the priest yeah but
then we want to how are we going to deny
what other scriptures say because the
other scriptures are going to say
something very interesting that we're
going to get into remember that this was
for the
priest what know ye not that your body
is the Temple of the Holy Ghost which is
in you which ye have of God and ye are
not your own okay so the priest was not
to drink wine doesn't say get drunk he
wasn't to drink wine before entering
into the temple and now today there is
no Temple that we recognize we are the
temple we are the temple so if alcohol
wasn't allowed in the temple and we are
the temple this is
mathematics if alcohol not if you cannot
do if alcohol minus Temple then it's
alcohol minus us that's mathematics you
cannot look at any other way so if you
want to say know that was just for the
priest then you're rejecting what the
word of God says when he says that you
are the Temple of the Holy Ghost that's
God's word that you're rejecting so we
have to look at that and say okay
there's a difference there's clearly
clean and unclean when it comes to wine
and and you weren't supposed to drink it
before you went to the temple we are the
temple now here's another
verse I beseech you therefore Brethren
by the mercies of God that ye present
your bodies a Living Sacrifice holy
acceptable unto God which is your
reasonable service and be not conformed
to this world but be ye transformed by
the renewing of your mind that ye may
prove what is that good and acceptable
and perfect will of God for I say
through the grace given unto me to every
man that is among you not to think of
himself more highly than he ought to
think but to think soberly according as
God hath dealt to every man The Measure
of
Faith I want to point out some things
that are highlighted here our body is a
Living Sacrifice that needs to be
acceptable to God what was acceptable to
God a blemish free lamb and we're we're
justifying putting toxins into our body
I'm not saying we're perfect but we
should not be
justifying purposely putting toxins in
our body and it says do not be conformed
to this world what is this world doing
drinking eating and drinking and being
marry and all those things right it says
in the days of Noah there will be people
that are eating and drinking and being
Mary and all this stuff be not conformed
to this world but be transformed I'm so
thankful that God transformed my mind he
renewed my mind this verse renew your
mind is the opposite of what alcohol is
doing to your brain it's shrinking it
one glass a couple of glasses a week is
shrinking your brain and it says but God
see this is the the contrast God always
says don't do this but do this don't be
drunk with or don't be filled with wine
but be filled with the holy spirit so
he's never taking something away and
leaving you empty he's saying don't do
this because I got something better for
you and he's saying don't be like the
world because I'm going to transform you
I'm going to renew your mind while
they're killing their brains I'm going
to renew your mind I'm G to raise you up
he's always trying to raise us up into
something better yeah and we have to be
in the perfect will of God and what
we're seeing so far is there's nothing
good about this stuff the the blessing
comes from the cluster the wine defiles
and do not defile your temple and it
says think soberly I think that is a
great choice word to use in the context
of
alcohol it's literally
saying um to be blameless and to be
sober now some people look at this word
sober and say that just means to be
alert that just means to be on guard or
something why do we do that we're like
we try to say well wine means wine but
we want to do mental gymnastics to say
that sober doesn't mean sober if I told
you I've been sober for 10 years and you
found out that there was beer in my
fridge you'd call me a hypocrite even if
I was drinking one beer every other day
I'm not sober no what does sober mean
this isn't California sober talking
about I I'm sober I I only smoke weed
and drink beer that's California
sober so Bishops must be
sober okay a bishop then must be
blameless the husband of one wife
Vigilant sober of good behavior given to
hospitality apt to teach not given to
Wine boom so you could say well that's
just for a bishop but we're going to
look at verses that that show that we
should have the same standard he's not a
respector of persons what's it also say
be blameless when we look back here it
said you're going to make you want to
offer yourself as a holy sacrifice
acceptable unto God blameless what is
included in blameless sober not given to
wine if we're going to study line upon
line then and we want to be a Living
Sacrifice that's blameless with a
renewed mind a sober mind not given to
Wine then we need to follow these verses
no priest shall drink wine okay so it
says neither shall any priest drink wine
when they enter into the inner court and
they shall teach my people the
difference between the holy and profane
and cause them to discern between the
unclean and the clean this is line upon
line we're seeing it again that wine is
clearly there's an unclean and a clean
wine if you want to be honest with
yourself and say okay there's two
different kinds of wine there's juice
and there's fermented uh wine fermented
juice and you put them on a shelf and
you say okay this is a multiple choice
question one of them is clean one of
them is
unclean are you going to get it
right clearly in its very name fermented
several people have been poting this out
is is rotting it is it is by nature
unclean right because of its dying
rotten spoiled form yeah versus clean so
we keep seeing repeatedly that this
thing defiles you Daniel didn't say I I
was getting drunk on it he said I I
refuse the wine I refuse to defile
myself it says that there's a clean and
unclean something about this is clean
and unclean and and to that we should
separate those two things and we know
that the Pagan King was serving
alcoholic wine and the blessing is in
the cluster this is so when you see it
it's so clear and I I'm not condemning
or pointing the finger we're bringing
truth here the truth will set you free
God's word is a two-edged sword and when
you really study it you cannot deny what
it's
saying and so it says that a priest and
a bishop should not drink this and enter
into the inner Court what is our body
the
temple but not only are we the temple we
are
also ye are a chosen generation a royal
priesthood Ood and holy nation A
peculiar people that ye should show
forth the Praises of him who ha called
you out of Darkness Into His Marvelous
Light boom I mean this is New Testament
first Peter he's saying that you the
believer are a royal priest so we our
bodies are the temple and we are called
priest so when it says priests do not
drink and do not enter into the temple
it didn't say don't be drunk it said
don't drink wine and enter the temple
we're the priests and we are the temple
I mean that's two against us we're both
a
priest is not to drink wine and enter
into the
temple so if we are priests we're equal
to the
priest and our bodies are equal to the
temple what's the missing
equation no wine this is simp
mathematics like when you look at this
and break it down we are not to consume
ethanol toxic chemical that shrinks your
brain and destroys your organs because
we're the living temple of God and we
are called priests and we're held to a
higher standard if anything be separate
from the
world okay Proverbs 31:4 says it is not
for Kings oh Lemuel it is not not for
Kings to drink wine nor for princes
strong drink well so you could say well
that's just for
Kings but you know the Bible does say
this
too yes the next one says and hath made
us unto our God Kings and Priests and we
shall reign on the earth so if you want
to
say well that's just that's just for
priests that's just for Kings then we're
denying God's word the blessing that
he's saying that we are priests and
Kings I'll go further than that we're
denying our inheritance to go to heaven
with him because if we want to be
priests and Kings with him we cannot
defile our bodies like this yeah he said
I will destroy those who defile the
temple which is
you man God's word is so good and so
clear and we don't have to be deceived
in these last days so many people are
going to be deceived in these last days
days because churches have been drunk on
the wine of Babylon the wine of
confusion which is doctrine of confusion
but we don't have to be because we want
to study the word of
God so do we want to deny this want to
deny being crowned a king in
heaven and what I mean is when we look
at verses and say nope that's just for
Kings it's a blessing or whatever we're
we're denying all the other
verses we have to cut those scriptures
out and say no I'm not a king I'm not a
priest I can
drink and I'm not
Daniel okay so the next verse says wine
is a mocker strong drink is Raging and
whosoever is deceived thereby is not
wise I want you to notice something
interesting about this does it say
getting drunk is a mockery no wine it's
a very definitive statement wine is a
mocker wine is a mocker why why is wine
a mocker I thought it was a blessing
God's word does not contradict itself it
can't say in one verse wine is a
blessing that brings joy and gladness
and in another verse say it's a mocker
you have to use your brain past the
point of just going it says wine
obviously if it makes you a mocker and
it makes you raging and it makes you
deceived the only thing that does that
whether clean unfermented wine or
fermented fermented is the only one that
does that to you yeah the difference in
clean and unclean and like people are
saying um you know you can eat which is
good or you can gluttony which is sin
that's true you can drink juice which is
good or a blessing and you can drink
fermented ethanol which is a mocker
which destroys that defiles the temple
Daniel says okay look not thou upon the
wine when it is red when it giveth his
color in the cup when moveth itself a
right at the last it biteth like a
serpent and stingeth like an Adder Thine
Eyes Shall Behold strange women and
thine heart shall utter perverse things
so the same author that right back here
said wine is a mocker goes even further
and says don't even look at it because
the Bible says like don't even give
Satan a a doorway a foothold you know
it's like don't mess around don't play
with fire we we say that term all the
time and yet we do it anyway don't play
with fire and so yeah anything that we
do that
offers an open door for the enemy he's
going to take that right if you bring an
idol in your home because you think it's
it's nice looking it's a nice sculpture
that's a that's a doorway well people do
that too and say it's art you know you
can't just redefine what the Bible says
have no graven images don't worship
idols same thing right yep separate
clean from
unclean okay so this is about glorifying
God in your body yes for ye are bought
with a price therefore glorify God in
your body and in your spirit which are
Gods we don't even belong to ourselves
Christ died he paid the price of his own
blood nailed to a cross so that he could
give us life more abundantly
and we're sitting here trying to find
loopholes of how we can consume brain
shrinking ethanol it's like a slap in
his face he's like I've given you my
word and I'm telling you there's a
blessing in the cluster and that Dana
wouldn't defile himself and to separate
unclean and clean and we still want to
find ways to justify drinking a little
bit why not because it not because it
tastes good because it makes you feel
different it makes you feel good and
that's the the that's
the uh crutch of it we want to unwind
from a long stressful day at work and so
we want to alter our mind even if it's
with one glass of wine one glass of wine
changes be honest with
yourself the same people who say it's
okay to drink as in moderation are the
same ones who say it's okay to drink
socially so why would you drink alcohol
socially but not consider juice or water
a social drink right because water
doesn't loosen you up it doesn't let
your guard down and make you more social
what does the brain shrinking toxic
ethanol that you're trying to justify
that's why it's a social drink because
it's altering your mind and that's the
truth and that's how addictions work and
Satan's hooks for temptation is always
using your emotions against you right
always it feeds good that's why we have
to put our mind and the truth before our
emotions right always because if if we
do everything that feels good it's like
hey this drug feels good this yoga feels
good this meditation feels good and
those things I've heard so many
testimonies of people who were Christian
who started out doing some yoga poses
and next thing you know they're talking
to ascended masters in meditation it's a
small crack in the door that the enemy
takes advantage of and you can't
convince those people that this is evil
because they're like no these are
beautiful beings of of light and I feel
the most love I've ever felt in my
entire life you cannot base truth on
feelings and emotion the Bible says the
heart is desperately wicked who can know
it it's deceitful above all things it's
deception when you feel good on
something that's bad that's deception
that's why the heart is deceitful above
all things and desperately wicked this
says whether therefore ye eat or drink
or whatsoever you do do all to the glory
of God be honest with yourself can you
drink that drink that D that Daniel said
will defile him that God said don't
drink that before you enter into the
temple that is called a
mocker pour it in your gullet and say
I'm doing this for the glory of
God no way be honest with yourself you
cannot it's impossible clean and unclean
don't mix you can't turn something
unclean clean and we have all these
scriptures that are saying this and
notice it says whatever you drink it
doesn't just say whatever you do do it
to the glory of God it's
specific why because there's a
separation of clean and unclean things
so I noticed someone said is there any
specific commandment not to partake of
fermented drink no but if we are
Christians we will actually follow the
Bible alone yeah and that means the
entire Bible right thoroughly in its
entirety not just the Comm commandments
so if it doesn't explicitly get
mentioned in the
Commandments doesn't mean that God
didn't address it elsewhere and that we
should look at that and actually hold
that that up as his standard for it as
well Thou shalt not get drunk isn't even
in the Commandments or being a sorcerer
it's not explicitly said beastiality
there's so many things that you get from
the rest of the text yeah from the
context of the Bible the principles of
the Bible are live according to this way
and I'm going to demonstrate it through
my prophets the law and the testimony it
says if it speaks not according to the
law and the testimony then there's no
light in them those are two things it's
not just if it speaks not according to
the law law and the testimony we have
the testimonies of Daniel and Paul and
John and all these people those are the
testimonies and we can't just say well I
threw I threw my Bible away and I got
the Ten Commandments on the wall and if
it's not on there then I guess it's a
okay right because then you'll be
getting drunk and high and well that's
how and I hate to say that but that's
how a lot of Christians are acting these
days yeah I want to ask you why is this
picture ironic what would make this
picture funny remember we said there's a
little truth in every joke but why is it
ironic when you see nuns drinking beer
if it's not if there's nothing wrong
with it it's like oh it's just a it's
just a cup of beer it wouldn't be ironic
but it is ironic because we know that
there's something wrong with this that
you shouldn't be drinking
beer and so first Thessalonians 5:22
says abstain from all appearance of evil
why does this look funny because it
looks like they're doing something wrong
and if it looks wrong then it has the
appearance of evil right and so if you
saw me walk into a
bar and I sit at the bar and order a
beer that would look pretty suspicious
that would look I mean somebody might
even snap a picture and post it online
and be like I saw Mikey drinking a beer
he's he's supposed to be a man of God
he's got a Ministry and
everything but I could say no it was it
was one beer I drank that in moderation
no it doesn't work that way this this
motto of all things in moderation is a
motto of
Satan like I does that justify all sin
like you know one prostitute a year or
you know it's just a little sin moderate
right no it
doesn't so this is a little puppet show
just to kind of
uh illustrate a point about alcohol and
I'm going to let you guys watch this and
just just take note of what's happening
and you tell me if it seems weird or
strange or anything like
that well oh hey
JJ hi what are you doing I'm just taking
a stroll outside it's a nice day you
know sure is nice day to drink a
beer yeah I'm just out here drinking a
beer enjoying the nature they're B for
why are you drinking a beer uh because
it makes you feel
good you want one I got an extra one
what no I don't want that stuff why not
are you
scared I'm not scared alcoholic yeah I
am because I mean have you H um this
beer and what it can do to you or well
yeah it can make you feel real good and
make you Brave and do all kinds of cool
stuff then you throw up in the next
day well I don't throw up I've been
drinking a long time and I can handle it
well still it's very bad for you that's
not bad for you my mom drinks every day
and she says it's good for your heart
it's the exact opposite it's bad for
your heart and it can kill brain cells
as well oh my goodness I still have a
brain I'm going to go drink alone see a
loser all right
bye hey JJ what's going on oh hi Pastor
Jimmy uh well nothing's going on
except when my well my
friend he offered me a drink and uh
what' you say I said no why'd you say no
because it's bad for you and it's also a
sin to drink oh come on JJ don't be such
a
squarey it's not a sin to drink it's
just a sin to get drunk really I'm
drinking a beer right now look at this
you drink Pastor Jimmy of course
everybody does it really yeah hey I got
an extra one you want one well I'm a
little too young for that am I hey if
it's not a sin you can't be too young
for it well I guess try it are you
sure yeah one beer can't hurt won't make
a drug I
guess e gosh that is disgusting what is
it tastes like that it grows on you
eventually you'll love the stuff it
tastes
terrible no get used to it go ahead you
keep that I'll see you Sunday uh
okay well all
right gosh
hey yes yeah can you spare some change
oh my you're so young to be homeless how
did this happen well all started
when my pastor gave me my first beard oh
how
terrible a't that crazy I mean me and my
daughter put this puppet show together
to show the irony because
as a as a preacher you wouldn't think a
preacher would go up to a kid and say
hey buddy it's not a sin to drink just
to get drunk here I'll give you your
first
beer but then that going to lead into
sin right and so some people say well
he's underage is there an age limit on
sin that's a question does the Bible say
thou shalt not do this if you're under
this certain age no Thou shalt not lie
means all ages and so you if something
is not a sin then it doesn't matter how
old you are it should be okay but when
that kid puppet drank the beer he was
like this is disgusting because like I
said nobody's drinking this stuff saying
wow this is a really good drink what is
this called No everybody's like it's
gross and they're like well wait till
you feel how it makes you feel that's
what it's all about it's all about the
feeling and so you know can you imagine
if
somebody you know became a alcoh coholic
because their Pastor gave them their
first beer it's crazy this is the
appearance of
evil so here's some verses that um I
want to show them all because when I
started reading the Bible for myself and
seeing these verses this is when I got
convicted about drinking my cousin was
saying hey man Jesus turned water into
wine and all this stuff but when I saw 1
Peter 4:7 talking about the end times
but the end of all things is at hand be
ye therefore sober and watch under
prayer and so some people are like no
sober that just means
Vigilant uh 1 Peter 58 says be sober be
vigilant now the these are two different
things be sober and be vigilant because
your adversary the Devil is a roaring
lion walking about seeking whom he may
devour what is Satan trying to do he's
trying to intoxicate our minds so that
we will not have a clear connection with
God so that we will fall into his
Temptations and his traps because that's
what it said it said wine is a mocker
and it causes you to speak perverse
things to see strange women it bites
like an adder and all these things
that's what Satan is his goal is to get
us consuming this
stuff and yet when the Bible says be
sober be sober in Titus 2 it says that
is or that the Aged men be sober grave
temp temporate sound in faith in charity
and in in
patience
so we might try to say look there's a
blessing in the wine and this and that
and how do we know when the when the
Bible says be sober repeatedly that
should be a clue and so let's look at
the the original well first we'll read
this verse because this talks about
sobriety as well you want to read
that for when they shall say peace and
safety
then sudden destruction cometh upon them
as travail upon a woman with child and
they shall not Escape but ye Brethren
are not in darkness that that day should
overtake you as a thief ye are all the
children of light and the children of
the day we are not of the night nor of
Darkness therefore let us not sleep as
do others but let us watch and be sober
for they that sleep sleep in the night
and they that be drunken are drunken in
the the night but let us who are of the
day be sober putting on the breastplate
of faith and love and for and helmet the
hope of salvation for God hath not
appointed us to wrath but to obtain
salvation by our Lord Jesus Christ so
when I'm looking at this God has not
appointed us under wrath and what he
said he said I those who defile
themselves I will destroy and so God's
Wrath is about destruction he's saying
don't defile
yourself because I'll destroy those who
defile themselves and what does it say
it's it's talking about um be sober and
what's it say in the context of sobriety
it's not just saying be vigilant it's
saying be
sober and don't sleep and don't be drunk
in the night but let us who are of the
day be sober so as children of God
Children of the light we are called to
be sober
and not sleeping and drunk and all these
things so the context of sobriety is
right there with alcohol so when you
look at the original Greek of these
things you see in the strongs where it
says abstain from wine this word that
means to be sober is to abstain from
Wine Not
intoxicated abstain from wine because
the this I'm showing this because people
think sober doesn't mean sober they
think sober means just be alert and be
aware but it specifically says abstain
from wine it doesn't say uh be careful
not to drink too much it doesn't say
only drink in
moderation
abstain from wine so when these verses
say be sober be sober be sober it's
saying abstain from wine
to abstain from wine keep over so now
let's look back at these verses who's
this talking to it's not talking to a
priest it's not talking to a King it's
not talking to some Nazarene or whatever
we can't play games anymore it's saying
in the end times the end is that hand
Satan's like a roaring lion and what's
it saying be sober be sober be sober
abstain from wine not drink in moderate
abstain from wine abstain from wine
abstain from wine this is what God
calling us to
do so when people say wine means
wine sober means sober the Bible means
what it says you know wine really does
mean grape juice or fermented wine but
when we just looked at what sobriety
meant it does mean Vigilant but it also
means abstain from wine and the the most
important thing is is that God never
takes anything good from us he only
wants the best from us he's never trying
to take anything good from us and Truth
never comes to offend or harm but to set
you free and so John 10:10 says the
thief cometh not but for to steal and to
kill and to destroy I am come that they
might have life and that they might have
it more
abundantly yeah so God is saying look
it's the thief that comes to steal and
destroy and corrupt and defile and those
things that's what that alcohol does but
I've come to give you life more
abundantly after all the things we've
looked at it shrinks your brain it
destroys even in one glass it shrinks
your brain and it defiled it would
defile
Daniel can we say that that's an
abundant life no Christ come to set us
free he come to transform us to set us
apart from the things of this world to
renew our mind
and
so this is what he promises us he's not
trying to take anything good from
us and so here are some images of of
life without alcohol these were people
who they were drinking and now this is
how they are after just you know 17
months sober look at the puffiness in
the face yeah I mean they were drinking
he looks amazing now after 17 months of
Being Sober
this is how it's changed
him um 21
or one year one year this is number two
one year sober look this these people
aren't even it doesn't even say they're
like hitting the gym or anything like
they just stopped drinking and it's done
this for their body look the structure
of the face yeah this dude on the left
looks older definitely look at this
lady after 8.5 months of of sobriety 8
and a half years sober praise the Lord
for these people this guy man he doesn't
even look like the same dude six months
in half a year of sobriety this guy lost
a a person's weight like lost a whole
person and he just looks so much
healthier
man
um look at this guy man he just looks
rough he's like man he looks happy and
clean and healthy I mean this this is uh
one and a half years a year and a half
sober so this is what an abundant life
looks like 300 days sober there are so
many people in the world who are saying
I want to be sober like the Bible says
and they're not even Christian is there
any Wonder now that when Daniel and his
buddies being taken as wise men to
Babylon and they refus used the king's
meat and wine why did they turn out
after 10 days alone to look healthier
right and they were wiser 10 times wiser
than any of the other boys there so much
healthier that the uh the not the king
but the guy who was over all that said
he's changing all their diets
everybody's going to eat pulse and drink
water yeah and so this is what an
abundant life looks like and I just
it man it's so saddening to me that we
are trying so hard hard to keep this
stuff and to hold on to one scripture
and ignore all the other scriptures be
sober your body's a temple you are
called Kings and Priests we have to
throw all of God's promises out the
window to hold on to one verse that says
the wine makes a a happy heart and and
we have to get rid of all the verses
that are amazing that are a blessing
that they they are um promises to
ush so what is the conclusion of the
matter God's word consistently warns
against alcohol's dangers describing it
as deceptive destructive and a source of
mockery and woe These Warnings support
the view that complete avoidance of
alcohol is the safest and most faithful
choice I agree 100% And I pray that if
anyone was watching this who was on the
fence and like you know what I I think
it's okay to drink but I'm kind of
feeling convicted about it but you know
I don't really drink to get
drunk weigh the weigh the pros and cons
out is that one glass of wine or beer a
couple days a week
worth killing your brain shrinking your
brain is it worth defiling your temple
as Daniel said is
it we saw that the priest is not
supposed to drink wine not be drunk but
drink wine before he goes into the
temple and we're called priest and the
temple um it says that wine is a mocker
so you know I also hope that this was
eye opening for somebody because maybe
you saw those verses and you said you
know what the Bible says to be sober and
I'm going to do that but maybe you have
friends that are like no it says Jesus
turned water into wine and wine makes
the heart glad and now you're kind of
like well I don't know how to explain
those verses or I don't know how to tell
that person that that's not true and so
maybe this will add Your Arsenal of
ammunition of God's word the sword
because if we're not in God's word it's
the only defense we have against Satan
and his deceptions the sword of the
spirit and so I just pray that this was
a blessing to you guys if you liked it
please give it a thumbs up because these
videos they need help in the algorithm
every interaction whether it's a thumbs
up a comment a share uh click the
Subscribe if you're new to this channel
we've been seeing the channel grow and
it's been exciting to grow this
community be able to talk to you guys
and find out what you want to talk about
I've seen in the comments that people
want to talk about certain things and so
let us know drop in the comments uh if
you see a verse that's confusing or if
there's a topic you want us to talk
about we'd love to hear that from you
also we can't do this without you guys
like we mentioned at the beginning we
are solely stepping out in faith
trusting in God that he's going to
continue to provide for this ministry
like he has for this first four months
and um but we can't do with that without
you guys so if you feel led in any way
to support this ministry every little
bit helps you can do so by giving to
cash app or vinmo or zel you can also go
to candid truth.org and there's a donate
button there that allows you to pay
through PayPal and you can actually do
monthly that way if you would like to
get something for your money's worth we
actually have a merchandise store you
can go you can find that on candid
truth.org and click the button that says
shop shop or store or something like
that and you can be like one of these
happy customers and um you can wear
God's word proudly and it will be a
light in this Dark World this world is
so full of evil and darkness and we need
to be a light in this dark world and we
need to be a Shining Light and be hope
to people so if you'd like to buy some
merch that actually helps us out as well
and then we can continue doing this
we love you we thank you we're so glad
you guys were here we enjoyed the
conversation in there and we'll see you
next time on candid truth